bonjour bonjour
je suis une femme je suis noir et je
suis ingénieur je m'appelle irina avoda
b et j'ai 27 ans je viens d'un pays à la
côte ouest de l'afrique
le bénin est depuis bientôt six ans je
vis en france aujourd'hui diplômé
ingénieur de l'ump peu je suis
consultante pour un cabinet de
d'ingénierie et de conseil et je suis en
poste à fedex en tant que chargée de
projet je m'appelle la grande cause a
dit j'ai 25 ans je suis un réfugié
kosovar
j'ai grandi dans un quartier populaire
appelée saragosse
aujourd'hui je suis diplômé ingénieur de
ntt et je travaille en tant que chargé
de mission transition énergétique à la
direction départementale des territoires
à charleville mézières nechako quelque
part nous grandissons avec des règles et
une éducation qui font de nous ce que
nous sommes
l'air de rien nous grandissons dans un
cadre qu'il soit géographique
réglementaire socioculturel et c'est
dans ce cadre que nous développons notre
appréhension du monde notre découverte
du monde
c'est cette appréhension cette
découverte du monde que grand sociologue
du nom de bourdieu a appelé l'habitus
dans ce cadre nous avons nos repères
tout ce que nous savons et nous pouvons
avoir les pressions que les limites où
les frontières de ce cadre sont figés en
effet à l'intérieur il ya tout ce que je
sais mais codm et références et à
l'extérieur
tout ce que je ne sais pas l'inconnu ce
que je ne maîtrise pas et bien
l'objectif de notre conférence avec
akron c'est de vous montrer que c'est
frontière où ses limites peuvent ou
doivent bouger dans certains cas nous
vous proposons maintenant de réfléchir à
la solution d'un casse tête
voici neuf points la règle c'est de
relier ces neuf points avec 4 est
rectiligne sans le bestiau
on va vous laisser une dizaine de
secondes pour réfléchir à une solution
et la projeter mentalement sur tableau
voilà le temps est écoulé on arrête de
réfléchir on pose les cerveaux et
maintenant on va vous montrer
directement la solution donc pour
résoudre ce problème il faut
littéralement sortir du cadre
à aucun moment la règle ne l'interdît
pourtant on pense instinctivement qu'il
faut rester dans le carré de manière
générale face à un problème il faut
apprendre à sortir du cadre pour pouvoir
évoluer et trouver une solution pour
irina et moi c'est 9,16 comme ses neuf
points représentent notre parcours et
comme sur cet exercice
nous avons dû sortir du cadre pour
devenir ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
maintenant nous vous proposons d'écouter
nos récits je te laisse commencer merci
je vais vous raconter une petite
histoire comme mon père nous raconter
son histoire à mes soeurs et à moi il
nous disait ceci souvent vous avez plus
de chance que moi quand j'étais petit je
devais marcher des dizaines de
kilomètres chaque jour à pied pieds nus
parfois pour me rendre à l'école le soir
en rentrant je vendais de las casas pour
aider financièrement ma famille la casse
à cet homme et locales béninois et
pendant la grande vacance jeu labouret
deschamps pour me faire quelques sous et
pouvoir payer mon uniforme à la rentrée
scolaire pour autant ma soeur et moi
n'avons pas eu à vivre les mêmes
difficultés que mon père j'ai pu passer
mes années du ce du coup primaire et du
secondaire sans grande difficulté même
si ma famille est issu d'un milieu
plutôt humble et que mon père est
également issu lui d'une fin d'une des
milieux beaucoup plus humble mais mon
père nous tenait souvent le même
discours
et j'ai fini par comprendre que ce n'est
pas parce qu'il n'avait rien d'autre à
faire mais parce qu'ils voulaient nous
transmettre un message
j'ai fini par comprendre que mon père
voulait nous dire à mes soeurs et à moi
que nous pouvions voir que nous devions
aller le plus loin possible en donnant
le maximum de nous-mêmes avoir des
ambitions nobles et élevé ne pas se
contenter de ce que je pourrais
qualifier de standards ou du minimum
c'était le discours de mon père mon
parcours a été influencé par deux
constats qui prévalait à mon époque au
bénin le bénin est donc à mon époque au
bénin il y avait très peu de femmes dans
le secteur de la construction cela
semble à un domaine réservé aux hommes
et c'est ce premier constat qui m'a
orienté vers la construction en partie
pour prouver que quel que soit le sexe
homme ou femme
il n'y a pas de différence est qu'on
pouvait aspirer au même chose j'ai donc
commencé après mon bac une licence en
génie civil
le deuxième constat était l'état de nos
routes dans mon pays
certaines étaient très dégradés et pour
relier certaines régions reculées du
pays
c'était des pistes aménagées il faut
dire que la circulation sur cette piste
aménagée était bien des fois chaotique
ce deuxième constat plus le conte le
discours permanent de mon père m'ont
poussé à aller chercher la connaissance
à l'étranger pour moi l'idée c'était de
d'aller apprendre comment les routes
sont construites ailleurs pour ensuite
apporter cette connaissance chez moi au
bénin afin d'améliorer la situation qui
prévalait alors après ma licence est
encouragé par mes parents j'ai saisi une
opportunité unique qui se présentaient à
moins unique parce que avec le recul il
ya très peu de ma promo qui sont partis
comme moi alors je suis parti ailleurs
et donc pour la première fois je suis
sorti de mon cadre pour cette première
escale je suis partie au burkina le
burkina où j'ai intégré un institut
d'ingénierie et où je poursuivrai mes
études et pendant cette année au burkina
j'ai choisi devenu continuer mes études
en france en me disant la formation doit
y être plus pointu différentes est
certainement ma vente et d'autres
opportunités et en plus la langue locale
étant le français j'avais un atout
majeur
et là je me suis dit pourquoi pas et
alors j'ai commencé les procédures pour
aller en france
et là je suis sorti de mon cadre pour la
deuxième fois alors faut se le dire un
venir en france il faut être vraiment
motivé parce que les papiers comme on
aime à le dire c'est pas donné mais je
ne me suis pas découragé je me suis
accroché et j'ai eu mes papiers et je
suis arrivé à la rochelle
arrivé en france j'ai eu mon lot de
désillusions et de déconvenues
en effet outre le fait qu'il a fallu
mobiliser énormément de ressources
financières parce que le niveau de vie
en france est beaucoup plus élevé qu'au
bénin il m'a fallu mois m'adapter bien
sûr rien n'est défini
rien n'était acquis il m'a fallu tout
apprendre de ce nouveau système
depuis le système académique différents
jusqu'au mode de vie sociale en passant
par les moyens de transport et en plus
quand on atterrit dans une ville comme
la rochelle à taille moyenne un peu bon
chic bon genre qui a très peu
d'étrangers et qu'on est la seule noire
de sa promo il faut en plus se faire
accepter et donc j'ai dû me faire
accepter
alors parce que certains camarades de
promo ne me répondait pas quand je les
salue et vous faisaient mine de
l'ignorer
eh bien je me suis fait des idées
ascq aussi en afrique en général on est
plus accueillant on est très accueillant
des étrangers
eh bien je m'attendais à bien plus de
bienséance choc des cultures préjugés a
priori mêmes sentiments de rejet mains à
force de persévérance
eh ben j'ai réussi à me faire deux amis
avec lesquels je suis toujours en
contact
à la rochelle et de la rochelle je suis
venu à lundi peu à lui été peu à lyon
nouveau challenge nouveau défi parce que
je n'avais pas le même parcours que mes
collègues de promo la plupart venaient
d'école préparatoires et donc pour moi
il a fallu beaucoup travailler
j'aurais pu me dire c'en est trop c'est
trop dur je rentre chez moi maintenant
je suis resté j'ajouterai passer mes
préjugés
je me suis accrochée et j'y suis arrivé
j'ai fini avec mon histoire
aujourd'hui si j'ai un message à vous
fait passer le voilà je suis aujourd'hui
diplômé d'une école d'ingénieurs
françaises ce qui a donné une
connotation particulière à mon parcours
mais pour cela il m'a fallu oser tout se
résume à ça oser ensuite il faut se
donner les moyens de je me suis donné
les moyens de sortir de mon cadre cij a
pu le faire je pense que tout le monde
peut le faire et que c'est accessible à
tous et enfin en europe
on a énormément d'opportunités par
rapport à d'autres pays où d'autres
continents pour certains comme moi il
est nécessaire de parcourir des milliers
de kilomètres alors que pour d'autres
qui sont déjà sur place tout est à
portée
donc il faut savoir saisir ces
opportunités qui se présentent à nous et
aller y aller pour atteindre ces
objectifs at war
merci non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis né en 1992 à ludwigshafen en
allemagne et parents étaient alors les
demandeurs d'asile politique
mais leur dossier a été refusé nous
avons été obligés de quitter l'allemagne
pour entrer dans notre pays d'origine le
kosovo par deux fois nous avons ignoré
la décision
la décision administrative et tenter de
revenir en allemagne de façon
clandestine
la première a été une tentative
ferroviaire au niveau de la frontière
germano-polonaise que nous avons réussi
à franchir
malheureusement les autorités allemandes
étaient là ont fait leur travail nous a
renvoyés de l'autre côté lors de la
seconde tentative
mes parents ont décidé de traverser le
fleuve oder qui sépare l'allemagne de la
pologne
je n'avais que cinq ans je savais
évidemment pas nager alors c'est mon
oncle qui va porter sur ses épaules
malgré le risque encouru
nous avons réussi à franchir cette
frontière
encore une la police
la police allemande a intercepté encore
ils ont entaché mon oncle nous enfermer
dans une cellule pendant une nuit
entière
le lendemain nous avons été transférée
en pologne
nous avons été détenus pendant une
journée notre envoi au kosovo était
définitif
le kosovo la guerre a éclaté au kosovo
en 1998 mes parents ma soeur et moi même
avons été contraints de fuir notre pays
nous sommes réfugiés dans un camp à 5 au
vote en macédoine
ce camp était prévu pour 8000 personnes
à la base nous étions plus du double des
soldats français veiller sur notre
sécurité ont joué souvent au football
avec les soldats français et à cette
époque c'était très fiers de leur équipe
nationale je sais pas pourquoi
par la suite la france a procédé un plan
d'évacuation humanitaire
celui-ci consistait à évacuer les
réfugiés par avion et à les accueillir
sur le territoire français nous avons
ainsi été reçus dans une caserne
inoccupés à pau nous avons séjourné
pendant six mois cette période a été
suivie par une phase d'appel insertion à
l'occasion de laquelle nous avons
emménagé dans une zone urbaine sensible
cette zone s'appelait saragosse et c'est
là que j'ai vécu jusqu'à mes 18 ans en
2004 j'ai intégré le collège jean monnet
au sein de mon collège au sein des
quartiers où la plupart des élèves
étaient issus de quartiers populaires
je n'ai jamais été un mauvais élève
durant toute ma scolarité mais je n'ai
jamais eu de l'ambition particulière et
aucune idée de mon futur métier
en troisième on va demander de choisir
mon orientation alors j'ai passé un
entretien avec la conseillère
d'orientation qui m'a lancé que je n'y
arriverai pas en seconde générale
le bep et l interruption
mes parents ne connaissaient pas le
système d'enseignement français et n'ont
pas pu m'aider dans le show de mon
orientation
aujourd'hui avec le recul j'ai
l'impression qu'on a choisi pour moi
mais loin de baisser les bras je suis
sorti major de ma promotion lors de ces
deux années de bep et un jour la cpe de
mon lycée m'a convoqué dans son bureau
pour me dire que je n'avais rien à faire
en bep et m'a orienté vers un bac
technologique plutôt qu'un bac
professionnel et c'est là la première
fois que je suis sorti de mon cadre de
référence
cette réorientation m'a permis d'accéder
à d'autres opportunités et d'exploiter
véritablement mais mes capacités
arrivé en terminale j'ai intégré le
programme internats d'excellence qui
permet aux élèves scolarisés habitant en
zone urbaine sensible de bénéficier d'un
environnement propice aux études
donc grâce à ma cpe j'ai pu obtenir mon
bac technologique avec mention mais
après mon bac guider par mon
environnement
j'ai décidé de faire un bts je n'étais
qu'un fils d'ouvrier je n'avais pas les
capacités de faire de longues études
du moins c'est ce que j'ai cru j'ai cru
que j'en étais pas capable et que je
n'étais pas légitime et en réalisant mon
erreur j'ai décidé de me réorienter
c'est la deuxième c'est la deuxième fois
que je sortais de mon cadre de référence
et toujours grâce à ma cpe j'ai pu
intégrer une classe préparatoire aux
grandes écoles
je me suis retrouvé parmi les meilleures
de ma promotion alors dans cette classe
préparatoire
j'ai passé le concours écrits puis les
épreuves orales à paris et j'ai décroché
mon premier voeu luhan tpe et
aujourd'hui je suis diplômé de l'estp
donc tout ça pour vous dire qu'on ne
choisit pas d'où on vient ni le lieu
dans lequel on grandit beaucoup de
choses et nous échappe quand on est
jeune et des opportunités qui se
présentent à nous et c'est là qu'il faut
faire un choix
nous pouvons rester passifs et
reproduire le schéma social que nous
connaissons tous ou alors sortir notre
zone de confort et devenir acteur de
notre vie je viens peut-être d'un milieu
défavorisé mais c'est moi qui ai décidé
d'en sortir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon ça ne se voit peut-être pas mais on
a eu nos périodes de doute de peur juste
pour monter sur scène et faire partager
avec vous nos expériences
on est très content d'être là et d'avoir
pu vous transmettre tout ceci et ses
messages et si on peut encore dire
quelque chose c'est on est là parce
qu'on a osé une fois de plus osé
toujours oser encore osé et c'est un
temps mais donc comme la diana s'étaient
c'était un peu difficile de monter sur
scène aujourd'hui
mais finalement on est très content
d'avoir pu partager notre histoire et si
on avait une dernière chose à dire à
tous ces jeunes tous ces lycéens et
collégiens qui nous écoutent c'est à
lady osé merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]